Cash strapped consumers should eat cereal for dinner
to save money. At least
that's what the CEO of Kellogg said last week on CNBC.
And if consuming chicken for dinner,
family should consume frosted flakes
or frosted mini hearts
as the rising prices at the grocery stores
are being felt nationwide.
And let me be very honest,
the rising prices at the grocery
are definitely being felt.
My bills have never been so high,
but that doesn't mean I'm going to the cereal aisle
where there's a bunch of bioengineered,
chemical laid
and refined sugar doused,
fifasate sprayed wheat,
corn, and soy products.
I'm making my money stretch by loading up my freezer
with 100% grass fed ground beef,
stewing meat,
bulk grains and flour,
and in seasoned vegetables.
And FYI, a 10.9 ounce box of frosted Flakes is 6 79
versus 5 10 for the same amount of organic
100% grass fed ground beef.
Like, are you kidding me, Gary?